for valentine's day he got me the rug in
the whole outfit he did and the little
genie oh wow he is the whole last minute
i do own the rug kim kardashian reveals
this super meaningful and romantic gift
that pete davidson gave her for
valentine's day and guys get ready to
cue the oz because it's cute af
on wednesday the kkw beauty founder
stopped by jimmy kimmel live with her
famous sisters and momager to promote
their new hulu series premiering april
14th
this is a relationship that i don't
think anybody saw coming from who are
you texting ken does his name rhyme with
feet
the two started dating after kim hosted
snl back in october and they smooched in
this memorable aladdin parody
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
kim is this the first time you kiss pete
yes that is
and when valentine's day rolls around
pete gifted kim with some of the props
from that skit for valentine's day he
got me the rug in the whole outfits he
did and the little genie oh wow he is
the whole outfit
i do own the rug cute right
yep well turns out pete is just a good
old-fashioned romantic because he also
sent flowers to kim's dressing room on
wednesday too
we had to carry in a huge bouquet of
flowers at pizza in here for you does
that make the other boyfriends look bad
i didn't know that happened until right
now yeah yeah it did happen
you're gonna have to call devin
devin being kendall's boyfriend nba star
devin booker do you watch um like devin
when he he broke the lakers
backs and hearts last night did you
watch that do you watch all these games
i watch every game unless i have last
night i had a dinner but all my friends
and family know that i like sit with my
phone wherever i am but kim and kendall
weren't the only ones dishing on their
love life over the weekend courtney and
her fiance travis barker practiced their
ideas in an unofficial las vegas wedding
ceremony about 12 30
on i guess monday morning i got a call
that a celebrity wanted to get married
they didn't tell me who it was they just
said it's celebrity
and we need elves and did the rest of
you know that it was happening were you
i knew and chloe knew i was on facetime
you were on facetime you knew what was
happening i was sleeping court shared
snaps from the rock and roll ceremony on
instagram wednesday yeah you know the
drill red roses leather jackets and an
elvis officiant
they did vows they did a lot of kissing
and dancing while they were standing
rounds
like court said the vegas elopement
didn't legally bind her and travis since
they didn't get a marriage license but
court says if they had it their way the
knight would have officially dubbed them
husband and wife there was no
like possibility to get a marriage
license at that hour we asked like five
times what do we have i feel like you
and i didn't make it like happen three
in the morning it was two a.m and they
were like it opens at eight o'clock so
you wanted to get married for real
but we're unable to get married for real
yes well that's a twist we just you know
we just did it anyways it's what's in
the heart
[Music]
you